[Music]
Myra that was amazing
oh thank you there's a soap Wow
well thanks for coming really nice to
see you my boy my boy my grandpa you
came how could I not show up with my
favorite grandsons performance and I
have to say that performance tonight was
interesting
thank you anyway I've got a meeting got
to go before I do just granddaddy kiss
Myra on the lips my rep grandpa I know
[Music]
is that it so I get
he must be nicely
so what was that with you and your
grandpa what did you notice something
weird a little yeah I guess I have this
little fear that maybe I'm attracted to
my grandpa my grandfather made all this
grandchildren kiss him on the mouth
I think it's cuz he wasn't a good
communicator and that's how he expressed
love so when I was 14 he made me kiss
him on the mouth and it moved why did it
my move when he kissed me
is it because maybe I'm attracted to him
and I can't stop thinking about it he
got super hard it's never been that hard
ever since
why did my move I can't stop
picturing things what kind of things
like licking his balls I just see two
giant balls and I want to put it on my
mouth do you want to more than anything
No
I said stop God what oh I'm sorry I
can't stop picture my grandmother's big
what's up with you fine
No
[Music]
it's your grandpa Pappy
come on I will say something let's catch
up tell us a little bit about you were
how's work going clearness the face to
break a thousand hearts so handsome
right runs in the family really does
yeah Myra I think he's choking
why are you okay
you okay yeah
[Music]
you